this is a new video Planned Parenthood
is getting very aggressive because their
there met their death throes with Donald
Trump in a very likely if not defunding
you're going to get less funding for
your murderous procedures this video
came out today looks like all the other
videos with the cartoons and the
graphics they seem like they could be
some kind of a children's show and
nearly everything they say is either
factually incorrect misleading or
offensive to the intellectual
sensibilities let's get into it it all
started with one woman I nursed her back
to health after a horribly botched
abortion she just barely survived her
body poisoned her fevers spiking before
leaving my care she asked how to prevent
more unintended pregnancies okay this is
important here as we continue to dissect
this video we're going to bring up our
social justice warriors slash leftist
lexicon unwanted pregnancies there's a
term they use that really means babies
were going to abort oh I get let's just
make that clear they're not they're not
saying like unwanted pregnancies like
wow this is a surprise well I didn't
really want this pregnancy but I'm an
adult I'll take responsibility for my
decisions unwanted pregnancies in this
video
and according to leftist assumes the
solution of abortion when I got home I
decided I wouldn't rest until I was able
to give women the knowledge to control
birth a woman can't be free
a woman isn't free enough it's required
no woman can call herself free who does
not own and control her body again back
with the social justice warrior lexicon
control their body and free I guess we
can put both those means abortion
dear mrs. Margaret singer I'm a mother
of five eight living one dead
19 children the baby only 20 months old
my house is brimming with hands and feet
and hungry mouths I hope you have some
information to offer I've spent almost
all of my married life nursing and
carrying babies I would rather die than
become pregnant again do you have any
advice the the context here really
matters because we're supposed to feel
sorry for these when they're talking
about having so many mouths to feed and
hands and facility have children I would
rather die than have an unwanted
pregnancy again how do you how do those
children feel imagine being that woman's
daughter imagine being that woman's son
yeah I'd rather die than have another
one of you magical mom said that on
Facebook and their kids were their
friends I would rather die than have
another little Jared mom how could you
say that I just I would rather die you
are my life's worst mistake and I would
abort you if I could have known but we
put in some cartoons and unnecessarily
dramatic music so we're supposed to
believe that they're compassionate let's
keep this in context go after a few
changes the organization became Planned
Parenthood in 1942 the organization
remained committed to serving low-income
immigrant women with the sliding scale
payment policy today approximately one
in five women in the u.s. visit Planned
Parenthood and three-quarters of those
women are low-income low-income that's
important because I know the left likes
to play it in any politics there is a
holocaust of black Americans Planned
Parenthood set up deliberately in black
communities a black baby in the United
States right now has about the same
statistical chance of being born as they
do abort it this was by design
this was by targeting from Margaret
Sanger noted racist let's see if they
get to that Margaret worked with civil
rights leaders immigrant women and black
community
but also aligned herself with eugenicist
it doesn't seem to make sense but way
back in the early 20th century eugenics
was an immensely popular social movement
one with the kind of widespread
legitimacy Margaret craved for her own
birth control campaign let's make
something clear racism and ableism do
not have a place at Planned Parenthood
and sure as hell don't represent the
organization's commitment to equality
well there's no question that Margaret
left behind a conflicting legacy it's
also true that she's a champ okay pause
real quick this is important I love how
they pivot from praising Margaret Sanger
the woman how great she is this sort of
biography - when it comes to eugenics
we'll get to what Margaret Sanger
believed in a second they pivot but
Planned Parenthood today does really
good stuff really great let's just brush
that all under the rug hip over there
with the word problematic let's just
brush under the rug Department well
let's let's see how problematic Margaret
Sanger was either direct quotes we want
to exterminate the Negro population ah I
know some of you will get mad say well
there's more context we don't want word
to go out that we want to exterminate
the Negro population someone argue that
makes it worse let's provide more
context just to be fair we should hire
three or four colored ministers they
didn't get the memo people of color
color preferably with social service
backgrounds and with engaging
personalities we don't want the word to
go out that we want to exterminate the
Negro population a lot of come for all
of these sources let me read some more
from you as far as what sheet she viewed
remember abortion safe legal and rare
was the mantra our objective is
unlimited sexual gratification without
the burden of unwanted children women
must have the right to live to love to
be lazy to be an unmarried mother to
create to destroy not as cozy as you
thought let's go to our final call here
as an advocate of birth control I wish
to point out that the unbalance between
the birth rate and the unfit and the fit
can never be rectified in the
inauguration of a cradle competition
between these two classes in the matter
the example of the inferior class is the
fertility of the feeble-minded the
mentally defective the poverty-stricken
classes should not be held up for
emulation on the contrary the most
urgent problem today is how to limit and
discourage the over fertility of the
mentally and physically defective for
those of you who don't know
her writing she saw black people as
mentally and physically defective
compared to white people she saw them as
inferior compared to white people low
income she meant black that's why you
have a statistical chance of being born
as much chance of being born into do of
being aborted as a black American baby
here's one thing they brush it under the
rug is problematic you are the same
people whose best proof that Donald
Trump is a racist to whom he will
probably topless Lee protests please
donate his inauguration is the fact that
he retweeted someone who happens to have
their avatar as a cartoon frog and
you've chant you've gone out and you've
protested professionally the Oscars the
cat the Golden Globes Meryl Streep
Robert a near racist xenophobic we can't
allow this he's not a legitimate
president woman says we want to
exterminate the Negro population you you
just shove it aside as problematic this
is why no one respects you this is why
you're not taken seriously Donald
Trump's too racist because someone had
Pepe the Frog in the Avatar the woman
who literally wanted to kill blacks and
was successful in murdering off millions
of them we give her a pass because she
claims feminism next clip example early
forms of birth control really didn't do
the trick
Margaret wanted something as easy to
take as an aspirin so in the early 50s
she worked to secure funding for
research have led to the development of
the hormonal birth control pill no big
deal it's only been called the most
important scientific advance of the 20th
century come again Lane huh who said it
was the most important invention of the
20th century guys let it out I think it
was Lena Dunham who said it was her if
she pops him like tic tacs is it Lena
it's like a Chinese restaurant those
mints you're grabbing out of a bowl at
lena Dunham's house and they're never
put to good use
when they talk about the most important
invention you're usually talking about
revolutionary inventions what do we mean
by that we mean inventions that change
the way you actually live your life that
fundamentally transform progress for
Humanity birth control isn't as years I
think yeah birth control is what birth
control more sophisticated than previous
methods yeah but you know half a lemon
wasn't as effective a rabbit skin
wrapped around your date with sinews
wasn't as effective what the point is
they did have losing the lunar calendar
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't full proof
I'll give you that but it wasn't like we
didn't have an idea as to how to go
about this the most important invention
of the 20th century
any idea was created in the 20th century
I've got a list Internet personal
computer automobiles cure for polio
ambidextrous scissors airplane space
travel we landed on the moon drinkable
yogurt which decidedly more convenient
and non drinkable yogurt penicillin
nuclear energy and a literally sliced
bread literally let that one sink in yes
literally let that one sink you but if
women don't have access and these kinds
of innovations don't mean that again
let's go to the definition here let's go
to our lexicon access means free stuff
access means free crap access means you
don't have to pay for your own stuff a
few years after Rome Planned Parenthood
and other allies lobbied against the
Hyde Amendment which would prevent poor
women from using federally funded health
insurance for abortions
hi passed within a year Rosie -
allatheena single mother was the first
woman to die because of the Hyde
Amendment Jimenez couldn't afford to pay
for a safe and legal abortion without
federal assistance the cheap illegal
abortion she got killed her
um let's keep this in context here when
we're talking about mrs. human is
because they want her again like like
Margaret Sanger they want you to think
she's a hero I don't know a whole bunch
about her she wanted to kill her baby so
badly that she committed a felony prop
probably not the Virgin Mary let's just
be clear about this here well we feel
that she wanted to kill her baby and
didn't have the money so she went to an
alley with a coat hanger and she died
sad
nobody's saying she should die but
they're saying here they're trying to go
on with the argument they're trying to
say that without free funding without
you paying for them women die from
without having access to two abortions
it's hard to find these statistics
because they throw this out a lot you
know that when the the life of the
mother is in danger well on average
there are 670 deaths per year based on
pregnancy in the United States so that's
a really small number that's not even a
percentage point but you're talking much
smaller numbers than that 670 deaths
with pregnancy per year they could have
been higher back then because whenever
the same medical procedures but you're
talking about people usually freak
accidents for example we have a family
member who had an inverted uterus almost
lost her
you can't know so you need to scale that
number back and you say no case 670
deaths related to pregnancy
complications per year how many of those
would have been predicted beforehand
meaning they would have known in the
womb that this would have resulted in
the death of the mother not at pregnancy
as a freak accident but could predict
this baby's going to kill you we don't
have those numbers and then you have to
scale it back how many of those that
they could have predicted would have
been the result in a death of disavowing
the doctors advise to perform to have an
abortion
so 670 in the United States reduced down
to numbers that we don't we don't know
because the pro-abortion activists the
abortionist don't want you to
those numbers we can't even find them
anyone who can help us please let us
know next clip
four months later fey walton became the
youngest president Planned Parenthood
has ever had as well as the first woman
of color pause I don't think they got
the memo that said woman of color the
preferred term from Margaret Sanger is
Negro at least on paper since Roe there
have been eleven murders
dozens of attempted murders and hundreds
of death threats plus a lot of general
rudeness okay pause for some hundreds of
death threats not gay Jared gets more
than that on his Twitter it's true he
probably gets more than that when he
walks into his men's club yeah YouTube
they said what 11 murders
dozens of attempted murders 100 and
general rudeness here's why this is so
important when how many people died in
San Bernardino was at 12 by 12 12 or 14
will pull those numbers up I think it
was 12 when 12 people are killed by a
terrorist attack they try to well don't
forget that there were abortion clinics
that have it abortion doctors who have
been killed
uh-huh throughout all of history in all
the numbers ever that you can find of
all the things 11 let's call it 2 let's
say 15 there have been 15 people killed
in the name of Islamic terrorism since
we've started commentating on this video
so they always try to trot out some
moral acquittal Christians aren't above
it look at what's happening with people
who bomb abortion clinics by the way if
you just set your stopwatch more people
just kill the name of Islam than all
abortion clinic bombings or shootings
that have ever occurred they bring out
the Westboro Baptist Church 14 members
two of whom have flippers yeah they
always have to bring out the fringe
groups and then that's supposed by the
mainstream that's supposed to be the
mainstream point even the numbers when
they're there because they're trying to
fluff up these numbers 11 murders
dozens of attempted murders and general
rudeness general rudeness when you're
trying to paint a group is hateful and
terrorists like general rudeness falls
at the bottom of the priority list but
it's all they had so keep that in mind
next time an actual terrorist attack
occurs in nature to say what about
abortion clinics well no you know next
clip
bortion providers didn't stop nope those
OGIS started wearing bulletproof vests
that's current Planned Parenthood
president Cecile Richards she's doubled
the organization's support since 2006
and raised millions to a Planned
Parenthood's mission of providing care
no matter what lexicon planned is what
they're saying this is let's let's
finalizing this their statement just
there because they're going to be really
mad when people want to defund Planned
Parenthood when they say more Planned
Parenthood's support providing care than
ever before what they mean to say more
Planned Parenthood's support is your tax
dollars your money your hard-earned
dollar going to provide care meaning
providing abortions meaning providing
the murder of babies across this country
they are championing the cause of
you-you-you-you or tax dollars and my
money being taken from my pocket to pay
for abortions all based on the concept
of Margaret Sanger who started this
because she wanted to effectively
exterminate the Negro population and
they are protesting because the rest of
America might not want to be paying for
this and you wonder why we don't respect
you if you liked this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside